ni assouplissement ni tour de vis le
premier ministre a annoncé hier soir le
maintien du confinement pour les 15
prochains jours dans les mêmes
conditions
un nouveau coup de massue à l' approche
de noël pour les vendeurs de jouets ils
viennent d'écrire à jean castex pour
réclamer une réouverture immédiate
le reportage à tour dorée des renault et
paul boyer le père noël remplit sa
autant click and collect à cette période
de l'année les rayons devrait
fonctionner à plein régime
aujourd'hui françois propriétaire de
cette enseigne ici à tours centre et
d'une autre à tours-nord pense à la
belle saison qu'il aurait déjà dû
amorcer il déjà genre embauché donc 3 3
6 personnes donc ça faisait six
personnes qui ne se fera pas aujourd'hui
au chômage ou même sans chômage que
c'est souvent des étudiants qui sont là
pour avoir des emplois complémentaires
une demi heure un chiffre d'affaires
d'une demi-heure à noël ont fait plus de
chiffre d'affaires que lundi ou un mardi
du mois de février
ici le click and collect est presque
symbolique
françois rempli à peine 30% de ses
objectifs
comme beaucoup de professionnels du
jouet il ne comprend pas pourquoi son
commerce ne peut pas fonctionner
normalement selon françois la meilleure
stratégie sanitaire serait d'ouvrir à
dès aujourd'hui pour lisser le flux de
clients et éviter les attroupements
si on concentre les achats sur une
période très courte
forcément les magazines ils vont être
assailli donc si là que se pose pas si
nous ont trait à l'entrée de toute façon
les gens attendront quelques pas alors
ce sera dehors ce sera dans la rue ce
sera chez paou mais en tout cas il y
aura toujours du monde de plus en plus
si on dilue et forcément ça mieux que ce
serait mieux les professionnels du jeu
et du jouet se disent prêts à amplifier
leurs horaires d'ouverture pour gérer le
flux de clientèle qui il l'espère ne
choisira pas les grandes plateformes
internet pour faire les cadeaux